welcome to this video complaints
McCullum and well played him three times
I don't remember anything yeah played
the decline Benko and he goes for that a
gambit line I don't really know that
admittedly but I'm trusting on mr.
Gustave solo always claims that white is
just a part of her well he is a pawn up
that's easily easily determined by just
counting but the OSS that white doesn't
have any that black doesn't have serious
compensation not quite sure if I played
right but really I don't want to spend
too much time here figuring out stuff
that I probably won't figure out anyway
in the end so I'm just trying to be
quick and see what happens really not to
d6 okay well I have 94 after Bishop 26
maybe he's worried about that and I'm
getting this Bishop
hmm yeah well looking at this position I
have to agree with yang Gustafson looks
like why this just better aiming for d6
now i really don't know if this has any
theoretical relevance ok I just I just
made things up in this as I went along
here um any I mean if five is a bit
loose there anything here taking not
with taking probably even though that's
not so bad i also have d6d six Queenie
six doesn't lead to much and i take c 4
is a roof but i'm not sure if this is
doing anything much right here for as
this something right before i can take
on d5 probably and be kind of okay okay
let's keep that power
should be 80 threatening 9 p-5 so if he
goes rooks eh I probably will play 95
and just that discovered attack is very
awkward and Bishop be aight i'll go ug 3
and he doesn't have a good coordination
wow yeah that keeps the material but
leads to an amazingly awkward position
so hoopty one or Bishop c4 I don't know
okay let's go look to you one
yeah I think this should be 60 no no
okay Wow many pretty good moves Queen c3
and Bishop t4 is also very awkward come
on just take a group do you want this
this must be strong really Quincy 723 a
surface is one problem um Wow Bishop t4
come on oh this this really must be this
must be a direct win there is no no way
that there's nothing possible here that
that didn't know they push up t4 maybe
just this one Queen back
Quincy 3 is actually also threatening
group d 8 but he's got you can move the
book back
okay I have to play move I really didn't
calculate this to the end but I think it
should be really dangerous so yeah this
is me a check this is made um so let's
check this I don't know what's best
Queen c3 is winning out I mean maybe
yeah I saw them all of course but I
wasn't sure if he can hold with this but
now aged for its pretty good them god
this is this is this is a key idea I
didn't see that one but isn't age for
winning as well I really think so Laura
my ID is winning as well I cannot it
cannot be as roop d8 made and blacks
coordination is a complete mess so um
yeah he has to to keep this covered if
he takes it i was thinking this this
gains his temple threatens this and
threatens Quincy five and I couldn't
believe he he can can cover all of that
now we have six Jets just hug him check
name made in one was a sudden end to
this but we're really impossible I think
we should be six it were there should be
six looked like the only only serious
try this ninety-seven check now stock
pushes on plus two women and this which
is about winning is strong and what
really shocked me was that he took on
the fire actually couldn't believe this
move
and this year I I could have could have
won even quicker uh-huh this is
amazingly simple threatening made I
didn't think of 95 every is it a night
be five is very strong of course but not
as strong as this sorry as a as this he
can only cover g7 by have six after
which i win the Queen ur amazing it's
very simple yeah the engine gives a
bishop age three year wow wow group d 1
wrote Knight g4 hmm Bishop h3 is a
shocker I was I was really expecting
this one and I thought I'm better here
still have that porn and it's not quite
clear what is what he has yeah so yeah
again Quincy 3 was strong check check
yeah that's just falling apart okay well
thanks for watching